you are father and son in real life your
father and son
on the show uh dan is is your dad
anything like his character
on the show i think there's elements
that sort of believe the real eugene
levy
sure i think particularly when it comes
to um there's you know it
part of the show takes place in a cafe
um and my dad has very particular eating
habits
careful um
[Laughter]
things have to roll out a certain way if
you're going to be dining
with my dad particularly at a restaurant
is this true eugene you're a little
persnickety when you when you're
ordering food
i have i don't know whether it comes
with age whether you become just kind of
a curmudgeon the older you get but
listen you know when i
when i'm going out apparently i'm an
embarrassment at times too my family no
one
said that it just the whole experience
has to roll out with the precision of a
royal procession in order for it all to
sort of
you just want things cooked
okay i'm sure you're getting things
cooked that doesn't sound like that's
the problem
no i don't think that's the problem i'm
saying that when you're going out and
paying a lot of money for
food you just want to make sure that
you're getting what you
order i mean that's it so i get i mean i
i get i'm
i get sometimes i i lose patience
in a way i've only lost it once you lost
your temper once
what happened uh well it was a i've
erased it from my memory it was such a
sparring it was a family dinner it was a
birthday
uh dinner for me it was a big night was
my uh it was when was it last uh
last winter okay so i was celebrating my
50th
and
it was a bit careful andy
it was it was a big night for me anyway
the service was kind of slow slow slow
slow slow by the end of the night now
we're waiting for
coffee and now it's 20 minutes and we're
waiting for coffee and i see the waiter
walking back and forth going
to this table that table this table that
table that table
i just need to interject just to sort of
color it a little bit when
things go wrong in a restaurant with my
dad tensions get quite high
so you find yourself slowly sort of
sliding under the table as the night
goes on that is so oh
that is so not true because i'm i'm i'm
just the i'm the picture of civility
when i'm
when i'm at a table but i did i did lose
it i did go up to the waiter at one
point made a b
line for the waiter and said simply
this is the worst service i've ever had
in my life and you are the reason for it
because you are the servant
okay and i'm telling you yeah picture of
civility just right now
and that's really horrible and
apparently i was an
embarrassment to the table when i got
back i mean you are
dealing with a table full of canadians
so the rest of us were just like we're
so sorry
sorry sorry but it was a passive
aggressive we're so sorry
absolutely now i have a question for you
so all we've learned so far is that
you're very picky
when you go to a restaurant and you
constantly lose your temper now
i didn't say that
what we've learned about it that's
pretty close now let's move on